>> Sean: SARA CARTER,
THANK YOU FOR THAT UPDATE AND
REPORT.
HE WAS A REACTION, OF THE BEST
COLOR, POWER GRAB,
JASON CHAFFETZ, ALONG WITH
FREEDOM CAUCUS CHAIRMAN,
CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGGS.
THIS HAS TAKEN WAY TOO LONG.
MICHAEL HOROWITZ IT HAS OVER 600
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE BEEN PROMISED THIS AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THERE IS NO OTHER CONCLUSION
BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW THEN THERE
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTED
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTEO
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTEN
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTET
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTEE
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTEF
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTES
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTEA
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTEC
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTEU
WAS PREMEDITATED FRAUD COMMITTET
BECAUSE IT SAYS VERIFIED ON THE
TOP OF THE PFIZER APPLICATION.
WE KNOW NOW THAT IT WAS
UNVERIFIABLE BASED ON THE
STEELE DOSSIER AS THE GRASSLEY
GRANDMA MOM SAYS.
WHY SO LONG AND WILL IT BE WHAT
SARAH JUST SAID?
>> I THINK SARAH IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN JUSTIFY IT
GOING ON THIS LONG THAT I THINK
ANYTHING PAST THANKSGIVING IS
HIGHLY SUSPICIOUS.
I DO THINK THAT ORIGINALLY THERE
WAS AN ANTICIPATION THAT
RUSSIA'S 20% OF THE REPORT WOULD
BE REDACTED AND NOW THE
ANTICIPATION WOULD THERE BE
SENTENCES AND PARAGRAPHS, NOT
NEARLY THE 20% OF PEOPLE
ORIGINALLY THOUGHT, AND I HAVE
NO DOUBT THERE WILL BE PEOPLE
OUTSIDE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, PEOPLE LIKE JOHN BURT
JOHN BURT AND IN OTHERS, INTO
OTHER AGENCIES, AND I THINK THAT
WILL BE, AS WE LOOK BACK, THE
REASON WHY IT TOOK MONTHS AND
MONTHS LONGER BECAUSE THIS
TANGLED WEB WAS MUCH FURTHER AND
DEEPER THAN JUST THE PEOPLE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND I
ALSO THINK IT WILL SHOW HOW THEY
MANIPULATED AND USED THE MEDIA
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES TO
MOVE FORWARD A POLITICAL AGENDA
TO THOSE OF THE TOP OF THE FBI.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN
ANDY BIGGS, WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
ANY AMBIGUITY HERE BECAUSE WE
ALREADY KNOW THE BULK OF
INFORMATION AND THAT THOSE
APPLICATIONS, THREE OF THEM
SIGNED BY JIM COMEY, THREE OF
THEM, WAS BASED ON UNVERIFIABLE
MATERIAL.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT EVERYBODY WAS
WARNED THAT NUMBER ONE, STILL
HAD AN ANTI-TRUMP BIAS, THAT
HE'LL HE PAID FOR IT, AND THEY
WERE ALL WARNED IT WASN'T
VERIFIED.
SO THERE REALLY IS NO OTHER
POSSIBLE CONCLUSION SO THEN THE
NEXT QUESTION IS, DO YOU SEE
CRIMES HERE AND WHO WOULD YOU
EXPECT SHOULD --
I GUESS DURHAM HAS --
THIS IS A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, THE RIGHT TO
SUBPOENA, CONVENED GRAND JURY'S
AND PRESS CHARGES, WHO WOULD YOU
EXPECT MIGHT BE FACING THAT IN
THE NEAR FUTURE?
>> WELL, I'M CONCERNED FOR
PEOPLE LIKE McCABE, CALL ME,
EVEN ROD ROSENSTEIN, ANYBODY WHO
SIGNED OFF ON ONE OF THOSE FISA
WARRANT APPLICATIONS, AND
CONCERNS --
NOT REALLY CONCERNED BUT I
BELIEVE THEY ARE COMPARABLE IN
SOME WAY.
I ALSO BELIEVE THE SOURCES ARE
COMPARABLE, ANYONE WHO
SUPPRESSED INFORMATION, BUT PART
OF THIS IS, THE REASON I THINK
THIS GOT DELAYED SO VERY MUCH,
IS REMEMBER WHAT HORWITZ DID THE
LAST REPORT, WHICH GAVE PEOPLE
LIKE McCABE, STRZOK AND PAGE,
HE KEPT GETTING WHISTLE-BLOWER
AT THE LAST MINUTE, SO WE HAVE
BEEN PROMISED THIS REPORT FOR
LITERALLY MONTHS WHICH TELLS ME
THAT HE HAD TO BROADEN THE SCOPE
OF HIS INVESTIGATION AND I THINK
THERE'S GOING TO BE A WORLD OF
HURT FOR PEOPLE, PERHAPS EVEN
BRENNAN, FLAPPER, THE HIGHEST